je suis dégoûté j'ai tourné cette vidéo
et j'avais pas me enregistrés et b du
coup je refais salut à vous oui je sais
j'étais trop près de la caméra avant le
dimanche je vous donnais toujours une
explication un truc qui allez vous
permettre de bluffer les gens et depuis
le mois d'août
on a arrêté ce rituel on arrêtait
d'ailleurs le rituel des jours de
programmation et du coup les
explications je les fais quand je les
veux dans la semaine il ya même eu des
fois où j'en ai fait deux par semaines
néanmoins quant à chaque fois arrivé à
dimanche vous êtes nombreux à me dire
allez où notre explication du dimanche
donc exceptionnellement aujourd'hui je
vous refais ça explications vous allez
donc bluffé les gens
si vous voyez cette vidéo c'est donc la
troisième de la série que j'ai fait
juste avant d'aller en suisse d'ailleurs
au moment où vous regardez cette vidéo
dimanche à 11 heures je serai dans mon
train direction paris
si j'ai mis ces trois vidéos là ça
voudra dire que j'ai pas pu faire là bas
où j'ai pas pu me connecter là bas mais
que par contre j'ai pu prendre de
l'avant dans l'écriture des vidéos de la
semaine prochaine et ça c'est cool
alors aujourd'hui je vous propose les
mentalités n'ont pas une personne mais
deux trois quatre personnes en même
temps
dans l'exemple on va partir sur 3 vous
réunissez trois amies devant vous leur
donnez un papier un crayon et vous leur
demandez de créer une liste de films
alors dix vingt trente films 25 30 films
c'est quand même un truc d'expérience
peux vous le dire c'est assez bluffant
pour donc ils écrivent ça le 3 si
possible des films qu'ils ont vus tous
les trois si c'est pas le cas c'est pas
très grave mais c'est encore plus
intéressant s'ils ont vu les films tous
les trois alors je vous le dis
d'expérience quand on demande comme ça
des gens de créer une liste sur un même
thème c'est toujours compliqué il ya une
espèce de blocage de recherche ou
d'imagination je ne sais pas donc vous
pouvez les aider les stimuler soit en
donnant vous même des films soit en
donnant des catégories de films par
exemple à vous avez pas mis de films
d'action ou à vous n'avez pas mis de
grandes comédies françaises
vous pouvez un petit peu les driver
comme ça une fois que c'est fait vous
allez leur expliquer ce qu'ils ont à
faire il va falloir être très précis
dans un premier temps vous leur demandez
à chacun de choisir un film mentalement
parmi leurs propres listes celle qu'ils
ont créée par contre ça doit être un
film qu'ils ont vu et dont ils se
souviennent alors ils peuvent se
concerter s'ils ont pas envie de choisir
le même film mais peu importe pour vous
ils peuvent choisir le même film ça n'a
pas d'importance et là où c'est magique
c'est que c'est pas très important que
vous les ayez vu les films vous même ou
pas ensuite ils se mettent tous les
trois en ligne vous mettez devant eux et
ils doivent tous les trois fermé les
yeux alors dans le temps c'est sûr vous
arriverez à le faire même quand ils ont
les yeux ouverts mais ça va être plus
simple bizarrement de le faire les yeux
fermés surtout pour commencer donc vous
leur demandez à tous les trois de fermer
les yeux et vraiment de le faire est
d'être concentré
vous leur expliquez que vous allez lire
la liste lentement et quand vous allez
prononcer le nom du film auquel il pense
à ce moment là précisément pas avant ils
devront s'imaginer en train de regarder
le film devront pas s'imaginer assis
dans le canapé etc
en mode attendent non ils devront
vraiment s'imaginer que le film se
déroule devant eux donc se rappeler d'un
moment du film et de le regarder comme
si c'était vraiment devant le comme s'il
regardait de nouvelles fines et c'est
essentiel d'être bien clair sur cette
démarche là vous
et donc commencé à lire leur liste de
films en prenant le temps de laisser
quelques bonnes secondes entre chaque
film
c'est important qu'ils aient ce temps là
pour entrer dans le processus d'
imagination et vous tout ce que vous
avez à faire
durant ces quelques grosses secondes
c'est d'observer les yeux de chacun des
participants
ils vont avoir les yeux fixes en
permanence et au moment où ils vont
entrer en processus d'imagination les
yeux vont commencer à bouger et là dans
les yeux se sont fermés
on s'en fiche de la dilatation de la
pupille et c'est ce genre de choses
c'est juste le mouvement qui vous
intéresse et comme vous pouvez le
constater quand les yeux bougent il se
passe des choses vraiment on le voit
très facilement
on peut donc observer plusieurs
personnes en même temps en plus si vous
êtes minutieux vous allez pouvoir voir
une contraction au niveau de la mâchoire
une espèce de tension sur le visage qui
une forme de concentration j'ai remarqué
également il n'ya pas d'étude là dessus
j'ai pas de statistiques là dessus c'est
juste moi mon expérience personnelle
puis le genre avait tendance à déglutir
quand il se mettait dans le processus
d'imagination mais deux bases fiez-vous
d'abord aux yeux ne dit pas tout de
suite à quel film il pense attendait
d'avoir bien finie la liste même si vous
avez déjà les films de tout le monde
il se peut du coup que deux personnes et
le même film et à la fin que vous leur
demander d'ouvrir les yeux et vous le
faites en mitraillette
toi tu penses à tel film toi tel film
toi tu es le film est là c'est le succès
alors évidemment c'est du mentalist donc
c'est pas safe à 100% c'est possible que
des fois vous ayez une petite erreur une
petite galère c'est pas très grave et
plus vous le ferez plus vous serez
entraînés et moins vous vivrez les
micros erreur c'est ça aussi qu'elle
vient de le faire sur trois ou quatre
personnes c'est que si vous avez trois
sur quatre
c'est quoi qu'il arrive une grosse
réussite c'est 75% de réussite
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et
que vous allez bluffé les gens avec ça
oui c'est un message subliminal quand je
peux les pouces n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà
fait le mental blog c'est une vidéo par
jour pendant 366 jours donc rendez vous
demain à 17 heures
ciao